각 상태의 계수와 2의 n 마이너스 1 정규화 조건은 일반적으로
연산자 o로 상태를 초기화하는 방식으로 접근할 수 있는데, 시작 상태는 모든 값이 0인 표준 기저 상태이며 단순화를 위해
이렇게 표기하는 경우가 많아요. 일반적으로 이는 지수적인 수의 C-NOT gate가 필요해요. 대부분의 경우 우리는
시스템의 특정 초기 상태에 관심이 있고, 그 준비는 합리적인 양의
리소스로 구현할 수 있어요. 예를 들어 qubit들이 서로 얽혀 있지 않은 곱 상태는 단일
qubit 연산만 필요해요. 이제 사실 트로터화에 대해 아직 이야기할 기회가 없었는데
여러분 중 일부는 이미 익숙하실 거예요. 본질적으로 트로터화는 행렬 지수화를 계산하는 방법으로, 비가환
연산자의 지수적 특성을 처리하기 위해 근사를 사용해요. HA와
HB와 같은 두 연산자가 교환되지 않으면, 영리한 트릭을 사용해서 각각의 지수인
e의 iHA와 e의 iHB를 n번
교대로 적용해야 해요. 여기서는 증명을 다루지 않을 거지만, 설명란에
이 내용의 간단한 증명 링크를 공유할게요. 핵심 메시지는 이거예요. 시간 진화는
매핑의 중요한 부분이에요. 트로터화는 연속적인 상호작용을 양자 컴퓨터에서
구현할 수 있는 이산적인 단계들로 분해해요. 트로터화된 circuit을 생성한 후, 드디어
매핑 단계가 완료돼요. 이제 circuit 최적화로 넘어갈 수 있어요.
이를 위해 달성해야 할 것들이 있어요. circuit의 가상 qubit을
하드웨어의 물리적 qubit에 매핑하는 qubit 레이아웃이 필요해요. 이는 하드웨어가 특정 토폴로지를 가질 수 있어서
물리적 qubit 간의 직접적인 상호작용을 제한하기 때문이에요. 반면
quantum circuit의 구현은 보통 모든 qubit이 서로 상호작용할 수 있다고 가정해요. 그런 다음 연결되지 않은 qubit 간의
상호작용을 라우팅하기 위해 필요에 따라 swap gate를 삽입해야 해요. circuit의
gate들을 하드웨어에서 직접 실행할 수 있는 명령어 세트 아키텍처, 즉 ISA 명령어로
변환해야 해요. 그런 다음 circuit 깊이와 gate 수를 최소화하기 위해 circuit 최적화를 수행해야 해요.
이 단계는 가상 circuit에서도 수행할 수 있어요. qubit이
아직 디바이스 토폴로지에 매핑되지 않은 circuit에서요. 하지만 이 중 많은 부분이
Qiskit에서 자동으로 처리된다는 걸 기억하세요. 이번 강의의 다음 섹션에서 정확히 어떻게 되는지 볼 거예요. 최적화 단계 후에는
프리미티브를 사용해서 circuit을 실행할 준비가 된 거예요. 대부분의 시뮬레이션 실험에서는 시스템의 특정 속성이
시간에 따라 어떻게 변하는지 이해하는 데 관심이 있어요. 그래서 estimator 프리미티브를 사용할 가능성이 높은데, 이는
특정 속성에 해당하는 관측량의 기댓값을 측정할 수 있게 해줘요. 그런 다음
오류 억제 및 오류 완화 기법을 추가할 수 있는 estimator의 최적 옵션을 설정할 거예요. 마지막으로
실험을 실행해요. 마지막 단계는 모든 데이터를 후처리하는 거예요. 이를 통해 측정된 기댓값이나
sampler를 사용하는 경우 계산 기저에서의 샘플 확률 분포를 추출해요. 필요한 것이
관심 있는 관측량의 기댓값뿐이라면, estimator
프리미티브에서 원시 값과 오류 완화된 값 모두 직접 얻을 수 있어요. 그런 다음 측정된 기댓값을
양자 계산이 필요 없고 고전 컴퓨터에서 계산할 수 있는 다른 관심 있는 양의
계산에 활용할 때가 많아요.
이제 IBM이 몇 년 전에 발표한 매우 영향력 있는 논문의 실제 예시를 살펴볼 거예요. 그 논문의 제목은
"내결함성 이전 양자 컴퓨팅의 유용성에 대한 증거"예요. 이 논문은 친근하게
유틸리티 논문이라고 줄여서 부르는데, 발표 직후 양자 컴퓨팅 분야에서 매우 영향력 있는 논문이 됐어요.
논문의 전반적인 주장은 잡음 있는 양자 컴퓨터가 127개의 qubit과 2,880개의 gate를 사용해서
무차별 대입 계산 능력 밖의 정확한 결과나 기댓값을 생성했다는 거예요.
무차별 대입 계산이란 하드웨어가 실행하는 quantum circuit의 정확한 시뮬레이션이에요. 이 연구는
양자 컴퓨터를 사용해서 사전에 해답을 알 수 없는 양자 시뮬레이션을 위한
텐서 네트워크 알고리즘과 같은 다른 근사적 고전 방법들과 결과를 검증하거나 비교할 수 있다는 것을 보여줬기 때문에 중요해요.
또 꽤 멋진 점은 이제 클라우드에서 IBM 양자 시스템과 Qiskit을 사용하는
다른 사람들이 이 결과를 직접 복제하고 검증할 수 있다는 거예요.
어떻게 하는지 안내해 드릴게요. 이 예시에서는 이 문제를 양자 디바이스가 이해할 수 있는
입력으로 매핑하는 단계에 대해 좀 더 구체적으로 살펴볼 거예요. 이 경우
외부 자기장이 있는 격자 위의 자기 쌍극자 스핀 시스템의
전체 자화의 동역학을 시뮬레이션할 거예요. 이 시스템은 횡방향 자기장이 있는 이징 모델로 설명될 수 있어요.
우리는 이를 매개변수화된 quantum circuit으로 모델링하는데, 매개변수는 조절 가능한
스핀-스핀 또는 Z 상호작용 값과 자기장 X의 세기에 해당해요.
이 시리즈는 실전 양자 컴퓨팅이라는 제목이에요. 그래서 이 실험에서도
결과를 최대한 좋게 만들기 위해 구현할 절차들을 논의할 거예요. 다음으로는
실험 결과에 심각한 영향을 줄 수 있는 낮은 gate 충실도나 결어긋남 시간을 가진
불량 qubit들을 제거하는 방법을 논의할 거예요. 이런 불량 qubit들은 이전의 잘못된 보정이나
qubit과 상호작용하는 2-레벨 시스템으로 인해 발생할 수 있어요. 하드웨어 네이티브 토폴로지에서 일부 qubit을 제거하는 것은
결과적인 토폴로지로 설명되는 격자 위의 시스템을 고려하는 것에 해당해요. 또한
트로터화를 통해 시스템의 시간 진화를 구현하는 매개변수화된 quantum circuit을 만드는 것에 대해서도 논의할 거예요.
이를 위해 나중에 사용할 주요 오류 완화 기법의 핵심 부분인
얽힘 레이어를 식별하는 것이 중요해요. 이 시점에서 여러분이 아래 링크된 튜토리얼과 IBM에서
제가 곧 논의할 모든 내용을 따라할 수 있다는 걸 알려드리고 싶어요.